uh
uh let's talk a little bit about
coronavirus yeah
so coronavirus um
you've you've been around if you've done
10 000 surgeries in your lifetime you've
been around for a while
have you ever seen a time uh i've only
been in a state since november 28 1990
which is
30 years is coming up in two weeks have
you ever seen a time
where a virus
has scared americans as much as this has
where it's forced the government to shut
us down
and handle the way with i mean we've
experienced aids cancer a lot of
different things that we've had
but i've never seen the reaction at
least myself i've never seen it but
yourself maybe you have a different
perspective on this what do you think
about the reaction american the world
said to coronavirus
no i mean we've we've never had anything
like this the the
closest thing was the h1n1 uh
flu uh but luckily
it wasn't even close back then we
thought that that was
you know potentially going to be the
next the next pandemic
and we if you remember we really thought
that maybe the sars virus the
original or mers was going to be the
next pandemic but
luckily for whatever reason neither of
those panned out
but yeah this coronavirus
i don't want to say we were caught
flat-footed because i think there were a
lot of people
who saw the writing on the wall saw the
writing on the wall
quite early and for
we could spend all day talking about
this for whatever reasons
um we didn't do a good job let me just
give you a california example
um one of the things that that happened
to us in california
is that that very early on uh gavin
newsom
uh shut california down
and uh shut it down early and shut it
locked it down hard and we
never really got you know that initial
big spike that
new york had or washington had and
we did very well and then
i think we opened up too early
and it was memorial day i can
i can remember uh was actually walking
on the beach in santa barbara on
memorial day
and there was still a rule that you
could not sit on the beach you could not
gather on the beach but the b
the beaches had actually been locked
down you you couldn't even
walk on the beach so memorial memorial
day came
the beach was more crowded with more
human beings than we had ever seen on
july 4th uh i mean it was
insane we actually turned around and
left and we went
what the heck well two weeks
after that you know we started
our first spike and we had opened up the
bars and we had opened up the
restaurants
and luckily uh we
you know clamped down we didn't clamp
down as hard
but whenever you see these sorts of
events
and it's happened everywhere um it
always these
spikes follow these these openings now
you can't stay closed forever and one of
the things i wrote an editorial
in thrive global a few months ago
i think one of the mistakes we've made
is
we let's use the world war ii analogy
we could not stay in in the bunkers in
england for five years while germany was
dropping bombs
on london waiting to develop the atomic
bomb the manhattan project
nobody would have been able to do that
but what
churchill says is you know we are going
to fight him in the air we're going to
fight him on the beaches we're going to
fight him on the land
we're going to arm ourselves we're going
to equip our troops
and we're going to fight and what we
haven't done
is we have not fought
this virus personally with what we
know can actually
help us fight this virus
and if we applied
what we already know about preventing
ourselves from number one
catching this virus and number two
if we get this virus making it a
mild illness rather than a lethal
illness
we'd be so far ahead already so maybe
that's a good intro to
maybe where you want to talk about yeah
i'm just wondering because you know i
so i remember where i was at when i'm
having a board meeting in l.a and i get
a call all my board members are not
coming from greenwich in new york i'm
like what are you guys talking about oh
it's coronavirus
you're serious yeah it's march 12th i
think that's the day
nhl nba shut down and disney and
everybody was shutting down
you guys are really not coming in late
no we're not coming this is serious
okay so i start calling around and then
i come back and i come back to want to
do my own research
and bring my wife mikey we were planning
on going to universal studios i said why
are we staying here because if this has
happened let's just go back to dallas so
we came back to dallas
and when i go back and i look at data
that i pulled up with sars
mers ebola any of the ones that you look
at
none of them we knew how bad they were
going to be
none of them do we really have the real
are not score on how
infectious it is right how how quickly
is it going to spread right
just like covet we didn't know yet we
didn't have that kind of data
it's not long enough for us to know that
kind of data
why is it that we didn't shut down with
the other viruses that they showed up
but we shut down with
this virus and how do we make a decision
like that because for me
you know how you want to go buy a house
or you're selling your house when you
want to sell your house you call your
realtor and say i want to sell this
house what should we sell it for
let me look at the comps okay what to
sell it for i know you want to sell a 4
million
but your house is probably an 850. i
think it's a million
it's not a million it's 8.50 and you
have this argument with your realtor and
then you get off the phone you talk to
your wife and you say she has no clue
what she's talking about the realtor and
then you finally realize
she has a clue what she's talking about
he said let's put it for 8.99
okay who
gets the comps to say how do we handle
other viruses in the past
if we've never shut it down on any virus
how much data do we have to say let's
shut it down now what is your
you know response to that one because to
me there's a part of me that wonders was
it a reaction was it an overreaction
was it an under i mean how do we know
where does the intel come from to say
it's the best thing to do right now is
to shut down
well i think let's talk from the united
states
we we did have
intel uh coming out of wuhan
and we did have intel coming out of
italy
um early on that this
this guy was a bigger mischief maker
than anyone would have predicted i mean
after all this is a coronavirus is
the common cold so one of the
the things that i think we should have
guessed
is that the common cold is incredibly
infectious it has an infectivity rate
that is so infectious that we take it
for granted
you know oh you know uh i'm i'm gonna
get a cold this winter and
oh well you know i i know i'm gonna get
one
and you know the person next to me
sneezing is gonna give me a cold or you
know
shaking hands i'm gonna get a cold so
i guess we should have known that from
day one this coronavirus
is is highly infected i think the other
thing
that we luckily knew
from wuhan and particularly italy
is that this uh we didn't know why it
was
but this had the ability to overwhelm
our icu and ventilator capacity
and that was different
than sars and mirrors and it was even
different than the n1
h1n1 flew and very early on
we you know again the evidence out of
both
wuhan and milan well in bergamo was that
this had the capacity to i mean just
literally wipe out our ability to
to take care of people so i think
at that point the the knee-jerk reaction
which
i'm actually i think the knee-jerk
reaction was probably the right
knee-jerk reaction
um just to you know prevent overwhelming
facilities and
again we're starting right now to get
right where we were you know in march is
we're we're heading to overwhelming
facilities
that have no ability to keep up with us
and in
places where one wouldn't have ever
imagined it um
you know i'm originally from the midwest
and the idea that north dakota
you know would have been epicenter of of
overwhelming their you know their
hospitals is like oh yeah right
you know we're all farmers who's going
to get infected
so night and day with north and south
though if you know if you look at what
south israel versus north very
interesting how north got
hit but south was you know good to go
and south had a different approach to it
than north took it's very interesting
what they did there
yep yeah so so okay so fair enough so
so then the next question from your
optics becomes
we're gonna have another virus in the
next 5 10 15 20 years this is not going
away it's not like 7.7 billion people
are not going to create more viruses
do you think this becomes the standard
for moving forward when we do have
another one any president that's the
sitting president
is going to be pressured to bring their
you know
expert from cdc whoever whoever that
doctor fought you of 2028
is going to be or 2039 is going to be to
say yep
i think we got to do what we did in 2020
let's shut it down for six weeks
do you think that kind of becomes a
standard well yeah you know
the other thing that's happened to us
we've all of us
uh have been used to global travel
um i think nothing of getting on a plane
or getting on a boat
and flying all over the world just
instantaneously and think nothing about
that
and i think um
as a consequence of that we've
now with this global economy um
we're gonna and it will open up again i
have no doubt about it
um and we'll get back to quote
normal and that will just put us in a
position
for the next great
virus to you know to do it again
um you know we forget that you know the
spanish flu
which by the way happened and started in
kansas
i hope most people know that uh u.s
troops that were trained in kansas
actually caught the spanish flu and gave
it to the world
but um and so the idea that this is the
chinese flu is sorry we we didn't so you
don't think it happened you don't think
it started in china you don't think it's
okay
no i but let's remember that
our coronavirus arkova 19
is the european mutation
of the chinese virus so
arkova 19 is the mutant so
we have the european um
believe it or not the chinese virus
of kovid was very isolated to washington
state
and a bit of oregon but the rest of us
all came in through new york new jersey
washington d.c
uh from europe uh so if you want to call
it let's call it the european virus um
it's better name but it's silly putting
a name on this stuff
but yeah we're gonna have another one
yeah i'm just wondering if it's a
standard like does a standard become
the next one we have to shut it down
again the next one we have to shut it
down again just to make sure we don't
make uh
because it's so much risk if you don't
shut it down right
well i think again i think we have to
for
this one this guy right away
in wuhan before they even knew what this
was there were
scientists saying this is really weird
people are getting pneumonia and they're
they're getting on a ventilator and we
have no idea
why everybody who's coming in with this
illness
is winding up on a ventilator and dying
we don't know what's going on
so i think that's different um for
instance
the flu absolutely kills lots of people
i
can name numbers of people that i've
cared for with flu
but what was happening with the flu is
that these people
got a consequence of having the flu
they had a heart attack or
they caught a pneumonia bacterial
pneumonia
or they had kidney failure but they
didn't
die from the flu
and we we have to make that distinction
it's the sequelae of having the flu
that you die from not the flu in this
one
it was holy cow there's something weird
going on because people are coming in
here and they're sick
and they're all ending up on a
ventilator and you could count on
you know one hand the number of people
i've ever had to put on a ventilator who
walked in on with the flu
um so it was a totally different animal
and so hopefully the next
whatever virus it is and who knows what
it's going to be
hopefully it may not appear in this way
uh maybe you know this virus will go
maybe this virus will attack the heart
more than this one does
maybe this virus will attack the kidneys
and we just don't know
from from watching it in your world of
expertise and how uh
uh we learned this one because again
this one leaves data for the rest
how do you think we could have handled
it differently this time around so we do
the right
time next time when we do get one
meaning if you're watching this saying
you know here's fauci we shut down china
we what could we have done differently i
know when
even originally when fauci said there's
no way in the world we're going to get a
vaccine within
18 months and within nine months
pfizer's coming out with the vaccine
that could potentially be ready it's a
90
efficacy he himself didn't think that
was going to be taking place so for that
for
them to announce that it's a pretty big
deal what did we learn from this one
that we could have done differently for
the next time around
well that gets back to what i uh
what we talked about before so the
people who are at risk for this virus
for the most part
uh have pre-existing conditions and if
you actually look
at what pre-existing conditions are
we're talking about obesity
we're talking about pre-diabetes we're
talking about
insulin resistance we're talking about
hypertension we're talking about heart
disease
we're we're talking about being on
medications
now hippocrates 2500 years ago
said that all disease begins in the gut
and one of the things i've learned is
i don't know how he knew this but the
guy was absolutely right and in fact
i'll pull away
and maybe your viewers can see this
the road to health is paved with good
intensity
and what what i've
tried to convince people is that
if you do not have
a leaky gut and if you
do not have insulin resistance
then your chance of getting
covet is quite low and if you
get covert it is going to be a mild
illness
now let me bring that home for an
example from last week i have i saw a
woman
who's been a patient from mine who's a
who's a snowbird
she and her husband are she's 85 he's
86.
she's been my patient he laughs at the
fact that she
does all this crazy stuff with me they
caught covid in march um
and she um
the it's night and day she had it for 48
hours she says yeah
you know it's kind of like the flu he
ended up in the icu for 45 days
um nearly didn't make it
uh it was touch and go but he's just
recently gotten out of the hospital this
was he went in him
five days wow 45 days in the icu on a
ventilator
and one of the things we've done with
her
is we've kept her vitamin d level
above 100 as i do with all my patients
most docs say that's toxic i can assure
you it's not
there's now six different human studies
that show
people with high vitamin d the higher
the vitamin d
the less likely you are to catch covet
and if you catch it
it's going to be mild the lower your
vitamin d the more likely you are to
catch covid and the worse it's going to
be
and here's 85 year olds who couldn't
have been
night and day difference she followed
what i asked her to do
we knew what her vitamin d levels were
for instance for vitamin d when i saw
her last week was 105.
and she said boy is he listening to
me now
[Music]